المحليات الصناعيه تحولت الى عنصر ثابت
فيما نتناوله يوميا من طعام وشراب ومن
حبوب وزبادي وقهوه سريعه التحضير كما تدخل
في صناعه العقاقير مثل المضادات الحيويه
هذه المحليات يتم بيعها باعتبارها بدائل
صحيه منخفضه السعرات للسكر الذي يسبب
زياده الوزن وتسوس الاسنان لكن دراسات
علميه عديده تثير تساؤلات حول سلامه هذه
المحليات الصناعيه منظمه الصحه العالميه
وضعت ارشادات تنص على ضروره عدم استخدام
المحليات الصناعيه لغرض السيطره على الوزن
توفر هذه المحليات المذاقه الحلو للسكر
لكن عاده ما يكون اقل من السكر من ناحيه
السعرات الحراريه تكون هذه المحليات ايضا
عاده اقل تكلفه من السكر لان مده صلاحيتها
اطول اي طويله الامد مع كثافه عاليه من
التح ليه هذا يسمح لبدائل المحليات ان
تستعمل في المنتجات التي لن تنتهي
صلاحيتها بعد فتره قصيره من الزمن
[موسيقى]